okay guys give the worst advice same  people are like oh have you bleached  your [ __ ] I'm like  what color is it  there were options is my color I thought  it was white is it not have you seen  you're like does this person know my ass  has he seen my [ __ ]  I'm like what do you mean he's like oh  there are vary of colors I mean it goes  there's a huge Spectrum it goes from  white to Yellow to Lavender to navy blue  someone has a navy blue [ __ ] okay so  this is uh  first of all can I say to begin with  ew gross I am thoroughly repulsed right  now I feel intense nausea I'll get sick  I can't be there that's a new one for  try to laugh you know I'm used to  feeling depressed annoyed miserable  while watching these but this is the  first time that I've experienced a  profound desire to go back in time and  gouge out my own eardrums to stop myself  from having to listen to that